saw policy driven definitely it's it's a
budget Street shooting
that that that you know hinders music
when [__] happens in Stockton it's it's
very small I've been there you know
small everybody went to school together
yeah related it's a lot different right
yeah but for you like do you think that
there's any
like progress in the right direction as
of right now people like that [__]
though like like I feel that's what's
driving it like people like seeing that
that beef and [__] and yeah and that
drama and [__] it's not good for the
human beings involved not that it helps
with it helps with the with the getting
the streams up and numbers up for sure
it's like a give and take though because
it's like if you lean into that [__]
there's like real life ramifications
yeah yeah for sure you gotta know what
you signed up for yeah I mean there's
been a lot of guys losing their life out
there too man like you know like the
like the slowby dude obviously rest in
peace I feel like I've heard a few
people losing their life out there
they're like I just follow the fizzler
Bro The Sizzler just be keeping me yeah
yeah
for sure